[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so just really days after the
killing of George Floyd started huge
nationwide protests we now have another
incident out of Atlanta where a white
Atlanta police officer shot black man
Rashard Brooks who was unarmed in the
back and this one the it's different and
it's not different it's different in
that there was actually a confrontation
during which the officer at least
claimed that Brooks was attempting to
take his taser and actually says it on
video and the other difference is that
it was a firearm that was involved and
it was a shooting death rather than 8
minutes and 46 seconds of an officer
kneeling on George Floyd's neck but once
again we have another killing needless
to say without yet applying more legal
terms for it but the family of Rashard
Brooks indeed wants murder charges we
don't know if they are going to get them
and so for me Pat you know I didn't
cover this individual incident on the
regular show because I don't feel like
there's any I mean we've been doing the
the systemic analysis for two weeks now
so there was nothing new there it's also
different circumstances in this
particular case but this may well Rhian
flame protests which had started to sort
of peter out a little bit over the last
few days what if it wasn't for the
George Floyd killing in the ensuing
protests I don't think that this story
would have gotten national attention I
don't think it would have blown up in
the way that it did and partly that's
because it's not as clear-cut as the
George Floyd incident where that was
clearly murdered I think and we'll find
out what the court eventually says with
it but just looking at the video I think
with our you know sort of human
understanding of what murder is that
sort of fits the definition with this
story because the man in question was
able to grab that taser it is more up in
the air I suppose the officer claims
that he was in fear of
life doesn't make too much sense because
they're willing to use tasers on
civilians and those are used as a
non-lethal option so if the civilian has
a Taser and turns it on the cop is the
cops like really at risk you have two
cops there it's two on one an
importantly Pat also shot in the back
right and that's a bit that's a big
thing if you're shot in the back yes he
was running away and you know now you
have to argue as the police that you
shot him even though he was running if
he's running away he's not a threat to
you so now you have to argue well I shot
him because he could have run and killed
someone else I get like it it is very
tough to make that case even if we
concede that the circumstances are
different yeah that guy's drunk you
shoot him three times in the back
it doesn't seem justified to me I mean
sometimes we hear these conversations
about how we can improve policing and
some people have the idea of oh in stead
of shooting someone in the chest
shooting me in the leg that's what Joe
Biden said recently and you know that's
maybe not the most enlightened view on
how to reform policing but in a case
like this if he had shot the guy wants
in the leg and that's just you know made
it so we couldn't run away anymore we
wouldn't have heard about this everyone
would have lived most likely and would
have been a better outcome so I don't
know if I don't know if this rises to
murder I don't know I don't know if it's
you know some sort of manslaughter case
it's not as clear-cut as the George
Floyd incident but it does look like
something did go wrong here yeah and it
was two gunshots to the back according
to the medical examiner Geraldo Rivera
of all people on Fox News plainly saying
you don't shoot anybody in the back here
police you just you just don't shoot
people in the back and of course we can
all dream up scenarios where it's an
armed person running away towards the
crowd of kids maybe you do shoot him in
the back in that situation but but
generally speaking shots in the back
raised major red flags for me but from a
legal perspective I agree with you Pat I
don't see serious repercussions for
these officers given the case that can
be made but we've been wrong about these
before we've been obviously how it goes
I mean watching that video do you get
the sense of that it was done out of
frustration like the cops we're trying
to restrain the man they couldn't quite
do it he was able to briefly get away
from them took one of the weapons maybe
he got angry about that and decided
retaliate by shooting the man I mean
that's that's kind of a sense that I got
out of people did not strike me that
they legitimately feared for their lives
yeah it seemed as though other emotions
were absolutely at play and there well
may have to be repercussions for that
even if we don't end up with with what
we would call murder in this particular
case a speaking of police force in New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo has signed
what he says are the most aggressive
police accountability measures in the
country and he has criminalized the use
of choke holds just weeks after the
death of George Floyd in Minneapolis
there were also be he tweeted as part of
this announcement that states cities
rather have until April 1st 2021 to put
together plans that will actually
reinvent and modernize strategies and
programs and if they don't do it they
aren't getting state money so obviously
cities are going to have to do it I
wouldn't be surprised if as April 1st
rolls around they will start to offer
potentially some extensions if not every
department is able to do it what do you
think about this Pat because on the one
hand it feels as though Wow
Andrew Cuomo is acting really quickly
and and that should be applauded on the
other hand there are criticisms that
this is a lot of posturing without
actually that much policy and sort of
saying cities just have to pretend and
I'm using that term loosely or posture
as if they have reformed something by
giving us a plan well if they have a few
things in mind that they view as
low-hanging fruit and they want to come
out and sign bills addressing those
things I think that's okay as long as
you keep up the effort and overtime you
like continuing to develop actual police
reform measures you don't just do it at
a time when everyone's paying attention
and then once no one is paying attention
anymore you don't even think about this
stuff so if it's just for that then of
course that would be wrong but you know
the question over chokeholds themselves
I think it's kind of an open question
right I mean I think it may be a problem
to say chokehold should be allowed
because oftentimes people don't respond
to them well if people can't breathe
sometimes that makes it so they were
they resist more
which may lead to the officer choking
them even more which is not good
other people have underlying health
conditions so that's really not good for
their heart and their breathing if you
have someone choking you there's maybe
other times though where a cop is in a
one-on-one combat situation right and
maybe the cop has the upper hand but the
person isn't entirely restrained at his
disposal the cop may have the choice of
punching the person he could grab his
baton and start hitting the person he
could grab a Taser or mace or a weapon
or go for a chokehold and I'm not so
convinced that like a chokehold is
clearly a worse options and then some of
the other ones that he has there well my
take on this is I think there is
altogether too much focus on tools of
force using the chokehold or not using
the Taser or not using the gun or not
and not nearly enough focus and training
on preventing any of those tools from
being necessary so like listen I am NOT
in a position to say chokehold should
never be used I can certainly imagine
the plausibility of if you've got a gun
or a Taser or a chokehold
if responsibly and briefly used maybe we
do prefer the chokehold in some
situations I'm not defending chokehold
but my problem is police aren't nearly
being trained enough in how did the
escalate situations so that you don't
need these tools nearly as frequently so
that you don't actually have to use
these tools and that's like the big
systemic failing of many police
departments in my mind that the lack of
de-escalation training is what's even
putting us into these positions in the
first place yes also what we consider
crimes in this country because if an
intimate starts over some sort of like
drug possession thing and then the
person who is a suspect doesn't want to
be arrested they start resisting they
try to get away the situation escalates
right and then that goes into the
de-escalation point that you were
talking about so yeah I think we can we
can get rid of like maybe a majority of
these issues just by like dealing with
the escalation or de-escalation tactics
and making sure that a lot of these
so-called crimes aren't crimes in the
first place
hey this is a kind of interesting story
to look at something totally different
it's a story about
orders between countries which are
interesting in a lot of different ways
politically economically and and in
other ways there was a I guess we're
what we're calling a confusion between
the border of on the border of Poland
and the Czech Republic where a Czech
Foreign Ministry officer confirmed that
on Saturday Polish soldiers mistakenly
stopped some Czech citizens from
entering a church that was definitely on
the Czech side of the border but very
close to the Czech Polish border and
this happened in a small village known
as Pelle removi I hope that
pronunciation is suitable it's right
across the border from Poland and the
imagine being told you can't go into
this Church in your country because
someone thinks it's actually in a
different country it sounds crazy
they're chalking it up to a
misunderstanding but this actually
reminded me of a point at which I did a
little bit of research into unusual
borders between countries and one really
interesting place to look at is if you
pull up Google Maps and you zoom in I
believe it's the sort of southwestern
border of India and you really really
zoom in you see some really wacky things
where the borders will go back and forth
in ways that seem completely illogical
from the point of view of topography and
sometimes you will have as an example a
river where the river seems like it
would be the natural border but you will
have the river and then a tiny piece of
land on the other side of the river and
then the border is just beyond that in
other words there's these little tiny
outposts they're not Islands right
because they're part of the they're just
the it's the other side of the river but
it is politically an island in the sense
that you're really part of the country
that's on the other side of the river
it's crazy
and typically every single one of these
Pat has some historical explanation or
story sometimes it relates to you know
village conflict from a long time ago
there are some really wild border
situations around the world and this
Poland check one is just the tip of the
iceberg for lack of a better term
yeah you see with some European
countries too and of course many
European countries are in the European
Union so the borders don't matter all
that much but they still want to keep
track of what's what yeah and I think
it's between Belgium and the Netherlands
where you have areas where it you'll
just be like in a town and you'll see
the border between the countries just
you know walking down the street or
there'll be like a house of duplex maybe
where half of the house is in one
country it happens in the other
sometimes they'll have surveyors go
around and they'll be like oh this is
actually the Netherlands where this is
actually Belgium turns out that's where
you live because that's where your front
door is and right in some cases rather
than the person deciding to move so they
can go back to the country they thought
they were living in they'll just move
their front door so that their address
changes and they're the the country that
they're from changes so I mean that's
that's kind of cool right I think it's
you know I think it's kind of quirky
it's a little cutie story here it could
be politically complicated imagine if
you're told you actually live in a
different country and then it's like oh
do I've written so now where do I work
am I like working in a foreign country
all like it can get very very
complicated politically when I was in
Belgium a couple of years ago I did a
couple day trip to master it the place
where the Maastricht Treaty was of
course signed and it's Maastricht as
part of the Netherlands but it is in
this very narrow little pub land part
but little very narrow strip of land
that is sandwiched between a friend I'm
trying to think now France Germany
Belgium and it was you know you're
quickly just going between country well
from one country to another and
particularly living in the United States
this is just a completely foreign
experience to us right we have the state
borders though like I went about four
corners monument last year very tense at
the meeting point of New Mexico Arizona
Colorado and Utah pretty sure yeah very
very exciting I actually did two
push-ups in all four states at the same
time that's so you had like one limb in
each state yeah exactly I had the plank
and then I did a few incredible so in
any case I you know we have a lot of
problems here in the United States but I
think we can say these micro border
issues are not a problem
that is very common in the United States
although I have to say Pat in the Rhode
Island Massachusetts border area there
are spots where you've got a lot of
little islands and whatnot where it is
certainly less than totally clear
whether you're in Massachusetts or Rhode
Island I don't think there's any
properties on them so it probably
doesn't make a difference
yeah because no one wants to live in
Rhode Island yeah you want to claim this
Massachusetts that's a joke that's
obviously a joke we love Rhode Island
and Rhode Island is grade and please
don't cancel your membership because Pat
said that okay that's gonna do it for
today
please remember to join the chess turn
are you playing in the chess tournament
pal yeah you're gonna play okay last I
checked we had over 300 people pre
registered now I last time we did the
chess tournament I didn't do any
pre-registration I just started
streaming 15 minutes before and we got
500 players we have allowed
pre-registration at david pakman.com
slash chess so we already have over 300
players I'm really want to say it I'll
say it on the bonus show but I don't
want to say it publicly in case it fails
I want to have a thousand people play
tonight that would be just amazing and
we'll see if we do it yeah it's
bittersweet to hear that we have more
players this time because the last time
I came in 160 6th place and I'm very
proud of that we have a thousand players
I'm not gonna comment 66 I'm certainly
not coming in hundred and 66th if we
have a thousand players that's for sure
so again just a reminder tonight so
Tuesday June 16 today 8 p.m. Eastern 5
p.m. Pacific
it'll be a 90-minute tournament you
don't have to start right at the
beginning but why not I'll be streaming
my participation and you can register
now at david pakman.com slash chess we
will see you tonight or tomorrow
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]